Imagine you're out camping somewhere remote...
...and you realize you need something from a convenience store.
Could be some water, some ice, a snack,...
...and then imagine such items being flown several kilometers...
...and dropped right where you are.
Well, this is now a reality in Korea,...
...and it's just the start of drone delivery services here.
In the case of CU, a major chain in Korea,...
...it started offering drone deliveries this month...
...from its convenience store in the eastern county of Yeongwol, Gangwon Province.
Available on Fridays and Saturdays to campus using a designated facility 3.6 kilometers away,...
...products can be delivered for free via a drone...
...measuring 70 centimeters in height within ten minutes of purchases being ordered via an app.
And CU is not the only one.
7-Eleven has also just opened a store with a drone station in Gapyeong, Gyeonggi Province,...
...offering deliveries over a distance of a kilometer in less than three minutes...
...also for free and also limited for now to customers using nearby lodging facilities.
These services are set to expand when government regulations ease further...
...after officials announced plans last month to support the industry's progress.